[Music]
thank you
Douglas Murray writing his column this
week that a monarchy is good for
politics in America he says they're
lumbered with political dynasties after
all like the clintons or the bushes
while in Britain a hereditary monitor
key gets that out of our Collective
system to explain Douglas joins me now
Douglas Murray welcome to spectator TV
now to start with we in the UK are going
through 10 days of mourning but it
doesn't seem like it's something that
has been well received across the world
well actually it has been well received
across much of the world except in
America by certain parts of the American
commentary act can you tell us about
what that's been like
yes the um the American public and
American officials have been enormously
sympathetic and expressed their
um their deep sadness and and you know
and their their feelings of of kinship
with the British people as as we go
through this period of national mourning
so that on one level it's it's it's you
know dignified respectful and and an
expression of friendship as well as
sorrow
but uh there have been sections of the
American Media the American Press in
particular who just seem not and bits of
American Academia who seem not to be
able to keep their mouths closed for
even a day let alone 10 uh to show
respect uh for an ally within hours of
hamasi's death the New York Times ran a
hit piece about her accusing her of
being connected to the crimes of
colonialism
um which showed not only an unbelievable
historical ignorance but a
constitutional ignorance of the way in
which United Kingdom is set up that was
quite staggering and then in the uh days
and hours that followed that that just
got worse more and more people jumped
onto that bandwagon uh the New York
Times even hauled in
um a British writers uh you know radical
left
anti-monarchists to attack Britain and
attack the queen
they then the America the American
broadcast media like CNN and MSNBC
decided that that the period immediately
after the Monarch's death was the
perfect moment to start talking about
slavery again as if the American Media
doesn't talk about slavery all the time
and as if Queen Elizabeth II had any
connection to it
um so there was this sort of it wasn't
just ignorance it was malevolence in the
air and you can see that as being um to
do with a late Majesty which I don't
think it does all you can see it to do
as having to do with just the
extraordinary
monomaniacal and uh really malevolent
way in which everything is now looked at
uh in America always through these same
lenses as I said in my most recent book
always through these same lenses of
racism colonialism slavery as if we've
never talked about them ever but for and
this is the ideal time to do so
you write in your column that people
have a problem with us and and privilege
Yeah ironic when it comes from the
American quarters because to tell us
about that well yes I mean the the point
to do with the malevolence of the media
is a specific problem of modern America
and that's come from people who just
hate Britain basically are very racist
against the British are you know very
malevolent about our history uh and just
you know Guided by a horrible animus
against us but there is another type of
criticism that has come up in the last
week which is from a more friendly
quarter as it were from people who who
you know feel feel uh kinship with
Britain and I've heard this a couple of
times and I've sort of thrown my own um
uh tuppence into this debate a bit in
America in recent days which is that a
number of people are said to me well
there's a problem with the monarchy
which is it it it's it seems to be the
epitome of unearned privilege and I've
I've rather enjoyed countering this
point actually in recent days because I
keep saying to people well first of all
you know that suggests that unearned
privilege is something which is unheard
of In America which is a hard position
to hold
um and and and secondly it actually
misses something very important and as I
say my column and spectator this week
one of the remarkable things of the
constitutional monarchy is that our our
national the inevitable National
obsession with dynasties is focused on
one Dynasty and that one that's lasted
of course More Than A Thousand Years the
institution of the monarchy
um and and to a great extent this is a a
political interest but it's also to do
with an inevitable human biological
interest which is our interests in
watching genes play out are interest in
watching generation after generation of
a family where are the black sheep where
are the where are the bad eggs who are
the people who really are the the
inheritors of great um figures of the
past and much more you know who's got
her her side of the family more who's
got his side of the family more these
are sort of interesting conversations we
all have in our lives with about friends
and Friends children and so on but
nationally that Obsession focuses solely
on the institution of monarchy and we
don't have as a result uh political
dynasties or dynasties As Americans
would put it we don't have that we we
have a little bit of it uh on the
political left interestingly enough the
Ben and the family you might say Harriet
Harman of the pakenhams uh you might say
uh the middle a little bit of
milibandian and of course rather
remarkably a little bit of hereditary
cynicism which is a quite amazing and
unforeseeable
um uh hereditary line in politics that
one is international that power family
and that one's gone internationally
exactly who would have predicted that 30
years ago
um but you know the
um we don't have political identities
nobody's obsessed in Britain with
whether or not John Major's children are
going to come back and save us or you
know whether the players are going to
run for office again whereas in America
politics is very dominated by a few
dynasties people are obsessed with it
and you don't have you know you can go
back to the founding and the 19th
century in America you could be Adams
Dynasty in American politics that you
can you can look at the the Roosevelts
for instance uh becoming more up to date
the Kennedys uh even more up to date
look at the way in which over the last
25 years it's looked at times as if the
presidency is simply going to rotate
between the Clinton family and the Bush
family uh you know a a look at the way
in which people wonder whether Michelle
Obama is going to run for office is
Chelsea Clinton going to run at some
point are the bushes going to offer us
up a new generation of talent
um and even though even the disruptors
in American politics Donald Trump is Don
Jr going to run you know think of this
in British terms and it seems absurd you
know
um are the Johnson children being lined
up for political office I would think
not
um uh so so as I say in the piece one of
the many many things that constitutional
monarchy does that is so good is it it
actually detoxifies the the political
Arena from having hereditary politics
hereditary electoral politics and you
know as well as providing us with
constitutional order and much much more
I think this is a little noted but
important role that the monarchy
provides it does seem like such
extraordinary and strong pattern in
American politics now you've already
mentioned this human desire obsession
with seeing how genes play out but do
you think there's something else here
that means that America is so prone to
these dynasties you know what's going on
you know this is no longer a coincidence
yes that's right well there are some
explanations you could say there for
instance running for the top job in
America means you've got to be able to
bundle a lot of money you've got to have
a lot of connections nationally across
all the states and much more and I
suppose you could argue that a sort of
that what we're really talking about and
this is what one American commentator
said to me that the other day is maybe
we're talking about celebrity really in
order to run for office in America you
need to be famous you know Dr Oz is a
good example at the moment you know if
you're big on television uh with Donald
Trump you can become big in politics now
that there is something in that but that
doesn't explain the dynasties other than
that they are well placed to bundle
money and so on but I think there is
something else I think there is a sense
that and this is a very
anti-meritocratic sense but I think
there has been a sense that some people
know how to rule now again in Britain we
get that out of the way with the house
of Windsor
uh in America you you just have this
sort of you know this this sense always
that there are some people who know how
to do it how would X know how to do it
they've never been near office whereas
if people have been near office somehow
they might be pretty naturally
um knowledgeable about how to run the
country I I do think it's an odd
Temptation it's an odd inclination it's
very anti-meridocratic it's certainly
um anti-American and yet it's holy
American so uh yes I I've been pointing
out to people this week that if they um
if they if if they don't if if they
don't understand what Britain is going
through at the moment and don't
understand the depths of feeling that
might not be the fault of the monarchy
or the fault of the British public it
might be their fault and they should
look at it more well just very finely
Douglas how has that gone down when you
say that on American Media
you know um a mixed a mixed bag
um I haven't yet had an encounter with
my friend Andrew Roberts has with an
entirely hostile interviewer as such as
he had on CNN the other day when um the
interviewer just seemed to want to rip
into Britain's uh history and Legacy and
it was left to Andrew to have to be
shouted over by the presenter as Andrew
was trying to present facts and the
presenter started saying you know this
is not a propaganda Channel
quite hard to hear a CNN presenter
saying that actually but with a straight
face
um and Andrew Roberts of course had to
point out that if the Americans were
going to start attacking her late
Majesty for the for the crimes of
slavery they should remember that it was
her very distant answers to George III
who signed the anti-slavery act in 1807
um many decades before America had a
civil war and had to kill 600 000 of
their own citizens in order to do away
with vile trade Britain did away with it
peacefully and then policed the high
seas for decades that enormous National
costs so I'm afraid as I say sorry to
return to where I started what we see in
the American some of the American as I
say responds to the death of the queen
has been just an alarming historical
ignorance but driven by an alarming
present-day animus and I think that
we've seen who our friends are in
America across the aisle but we've also
seen particularly American Media who's
some really vitriolic enemies of Britain
are well Douglas you are always well
Pokemon spectator TV thank you so much
[Music]